we
uh we left off last wednesday
last week wednesday so it's been a while
so i wanted just to pick up
where we left off and then cover some
new things
um today um
but where we left off was with this
diagram okay
and um and i kind of you know i kind of
went through it and i went through it so
quickly but i want to make sure you
understand it
very well because this is such an
important kind of diagram
and we'll see it again and you may see
it again in other classes this is a
diagram of attraction
and repulsion coming together in a
balance
to form a bond so so you know last
wednesday just to remind you we made our
first
bond right we made the ionic bond
and and i showed you how that worked
because in this case the attraction
the force of attraction is the coulomb
potential
right remember that goes as minus a
constant
times uh just write it down because why
not
you're using it in your goody bag right
so the coulomb energy here
goes as minus some constant
times the charges the two charges
divided by the distance between those
charges
that's an energy it's an energy of
attraction but you know
so here's the thing though right so if
you have a plus and a minus charge those
are each one
right charge of electron um and then the
distance between them when it's really
far
this this energy is pretty weak so
that's this green curve here but as it
gets closer and closer
that energy gets lower and lower and
remember
happiness is lower energy right these
atoms want to find their happy place
and they see each other like well we can
be happier if we're closer
until a certain thing happens which is
then
they've got similar charges like the
electron shells
negative charge negative charge shelf
kind of coming too close
that's the the forces of repulsion
and so that nets in a total energy curve
which is this
this white line here the green and the
red then you got the the white line
there
which is the total energy because if
they came too close then
you're going to be on this thing and
you're just going to be you know all
those electrons are going to be
overlapping each other
and very unhappy right
so this is what we do and and we said
okay this is the bond
of an atom and another atom an ion
and another ion a cation and an anion
we did all this wednesday i'm just
getting us back in the mood
right and what i told you is that that
bond energy
is related to the lattice energy right i
mean now technically
the lattice energy is
and this is something you're playing
around with the lattice energy
would be the energy that it takes to go
from
those ions sodium plus in the gas phase
right we put that little guy there now
that is something that's going to keep
coming too it's a notation i've been
sneaking in
gas phase right plus chlorine
ion gas phase and they came together
to make nacl
ran out of room solid but i put it
underneath
solid sodium that's salt now the lattice
energy
is the energy that it takes to go from
these ions to the solid and
as you can see well here i just did two
ions
but the lattice energy is going to be
related to that bond energy
right okay so the lattice energy of the
solid that you make
is going to be and ionic solids there's
a whole bunch of
materials that form solids this way
they're ionic solids they have
properties
that are general they're not always
they're not always these properties but
for the most part these are the
properties of ionic solids right they
tend to be
solid at room temperature they tend to
have high
melting and boiling points they're often
transparent and the visible they can
they're mostly electrical insulators
they're hard and brittle
soluble in water but you're seeing
in your goodie bag you're saying that's
not always true because
sometimes most of the time there but if
this lattice energy is too high
right then it may not even dissolve it
may still be an eye but
this may be some really really strong
ionic solid right but these are the
general properties
of ionic solids okay we'll come back as
we learn about other solids
wednesday um to
the differences in properties between
different types of solids
okay so that's where we ended now we've
got we've
now to do this to get to here
we had to make ions and so we've been
talking about ions and we're going to
keep talking about ions because
that's a very important part of how
atoms see each other
right am i seeing you as a neutral atom
with all your electrons in your shell or
am i seeing you with a charge uh missing
or not that makes a big difference
right in how they approach each other
and therefore how they bond
right which is a critical part of of
what we need to learn this semester
and so you know we showed this which is
you know
sometimes atoms actually don't mind
losing
an electron right don't mind don't mind
is like happiness level which has to do
with energy
and so if we want to look at this more
formally we would look at for example
this chart from april which is the first
ionization energy right now that's
exactly that's something that we talked
about
right so the first ionization energy
which is how much energy it takes to
remove
an electron from the outer shell the
most outer shell electron the first
one you would take away that's the first
ionization energy
all right and we saw uh again
getting us back in the mood oh i've got
colors there look so if you started for
example let's start let's just take a
look at this
okay so here here we are at lithium
i'm going to start here and that's first
ionization energy and this is just the
atomic number
so there's lithium and remember we
looked at this last week
lithium and beryllium okay so if you
look at that we say
okay so for lithium you had three
electrons
in the core so there's lithium right and
there's
the lithium oh this is so fun because
now we know what to call this
1s2 right and then we have another shell
these are just pictor the electron is
not in an orbit
it's in an orbital it's not
moving around like this that's our
classical mines
fighting and it's got one more electron
why did i draw a dash it's got one more
electron there in the 2s
shell and that's lithium okay but now
we're going to go from lithium to
beryllium and and we talked about
so beryllium now is going to add okay
it's going to add a
another proton it's got all of them but
i'm showing the one that was added
and it's also going to add an electron
here
but see for beryllium this
this electron is not
really not shielded anymore not shielded
more for the most part
you know it went into the same shell the
same
you know the same n right and the same l
same shape same quantum number so it's
there's nothing else shielding and yet
there's a whole other proton
and that's why beryllium is smaller
this is all stuff we talked about
wednesday but see look that's
also why it's harder to pull
the outer electron off of beryllium
there it is than lithium
so those really go together right the
rate all the radius stuff we talked
about
holds you know that same kind of logic
in terms of how these electrons are with
respect to their nucleus
holds for ionization energy now
let's add let's go to boron
so if we go to boron now
we're going over look at what happened
look at that we went from there to there
and the ionization energy got lower
well that's also something we can
understand because now
we're putting it into the 2p
okay so so if i do that it would be
i'm going to put it under here 2s2
right and now if i go to boron
i'm going to put it here in a 2p shell
so i'm starting
a new l now remember
that means the shape the quantum number
is still two but the shape of the
orbital is different
and now we know also from something we
learned last week
that because of orbital penetration the
energies of the 2p and 2s orbitals are
not the same
right the s energies are a little lower
and it's get it lets those electrons get
a little bit closer to that positive
charge that they want so badly
so we know that this is going to be a
little further out
and so there's a little bit of shielding
little
shielding that you get for this
plus orbital penetration that we talked
about
and that puts it further out
right and therefore the attraction is a
little less and therefore
the ionization energy went down yeah and
now we're going to fill those up but
it's the same thing as before now you're
not going further out you're just adding
and you're not really screening while
you add right
and so you're adding electrons into this
2p orbital but you're also adding all
this positive charge
salute and and so the ionization energy
is going to go up
except look at that oh half filling
right there half filling a little extra
stability remember we talked about
exceptions right half filling
half filling and so you see now you can
see we can understand these trends that
were being measured
right at the time these ionization
potentials but now we really can
understand them
and you can group them and you can see
if you group them
remember we also grouped the periodic
table a little bit by electron filling
quantum numbers right you had the s and
p blocks
those are also often called the main
group elements they're
in the first couple of rows of those
they're the the most abundant elements
right um and and so those are and those
tr but those trends now you fully
understand from
the the quantum mechanical solution to
the atom
right and the electron filling of those
orbitals we can actually really
understand it all right
and so that's the and then the same
thing happens with the d
it's a little more complicated by the
way these are often called transition
metals
the d block i told you about the d block
last week they're also called transition
metals
and the word metal is something we'll
talk a lot about in a few weeks when we
make metals
but they're called transitions because
literally they transition
in the filling they transition they you
you're filling d
orbitals right transition you're kind of
and that makes it a little more complex
in terms of what happens
but the same trends hold the same trends
hold you see
you as you add more d electrons the
ionization energy keeps going up okay
now this is extremely important this
ionization energy
the first ionization energy is very
important because it tells you so much
about
you know the outer electron whether an
atom is going to be an anion or a cation
but all of the ionization you could you
could throw a whole lot of energy at
these atoms
and they'll all come off right and and
so you know
so we we played with this kind of energy
this is visible light you had your goody
bag too
you got a spectrometer you can see lines
in here this is a continuous spectrum
but you see you got this whole all these
different wavelengths
right and and they have and now you see
this and you don't just think about
colors
you think about energies right and and
so if you think
that way because i want to know how can
i measure
how can i measure these things ah stop
better all right and so if i you know
if i look at energies oh
enter energies i've got like the visible
right which is around oh i don't know
say 2 to 6 ev
that's pretty high energy and then
you've got well now
can i shine visible light and and kick
out
you know a lithium electron well the
answer is
roughly yes if it's if it's you know the
lithium energy ionization
oh let's just go back and look that
first ionization energy
520 kilojoules per mole i know that's
5.4
ev ish because i don't mind going back
and forth
right kilojoules per mole of electrons
joules ev
moles you can go back and forth but
that's right around here
so i could shine visible light and
potentially knock that out but see
if i wanted the 1s electron of lithium
well that's it's much much lower in
energy because remember we talk about
it goes in and in each time i add charge
and so it would take 122 electron volts
to knock that out
right and so but we have that kind of
light
right the uv the uv would be something
like
oh 10 to 100 and then if we really want
to blast these we could go
x-rays are we going to have fun with
x-rays
later in the semester and this would go
to something like a hundred thousand
and so i got it you know if i wanted to
i could shine light
and ionize the whole thing and that is
in fact
one of the single most important
experiments we do to characterize
materials and so i want you to know
about it
it's called photoelectron spectroscopy
photo
electron
spectroscopy
and for short we will not
write that out ever again i will write
out pes
photoelectron spectroscopy now this is a
characterization
tool i'm basically saying well what you
know i need energy i'm going to get it
from
some photon source but i'm going to get
enough to just blast all the electrons
out of this material out of this atom
because for now our material they're
just atoms and i want to know about
these atoms
okay so let's take a look so what
happens when i do this well
let's see first of all i've got some
energy
that we know is h new it's dependent on
the frequency
there are the frequencies they're the no
they're there
okay and so now i've got some adam
here and what do i do well i look
does anything happen no what about now i
don't know
okay what about now oh all of a sudden
they come flying
out electrons right
and i measure their energy
it kind of it goes right back to the
photoelectric effect right that einstein
was doing he was shining visible-ish
light
onto metals and seeing one electro but
now i'm shining all sorts of light
onto an atom and i want them all to come
out not just the outer one
and so well you can see if i measure
so now i'm going to measure
the kinetic energy of these and
the ionization energy of that electron
is going to equal
how whatever the energy of the incident
photon was
minus the kinetic energy of the electron
right that's what i want i want that
ionization energy
this is just to be clear ionization
energy and like i said i want it all
not just the first i want the second the
third so now you see how so this is the
experiment that you do what are the
results
well the results are really just what
we've been doing but you turn it over
so let's look at hydrogen okay now what
have we been doing what do i mean by
that what we've been doing is we've been
going like this
what's that okay this is hydrogen 1s1 i
could do that or i could just label it
the 1s and then you see the one electron
right there
now if i if i shine light on this
and i measure the way that you do a pes
for hydrogen is you would look at the
ionization energy
on the x-axis and this would be the
relative
electron count on the y-axis so you're
just counting
right and what you would see in hydrogen
is there'd be a peak
it'd look like this that's it
if all the electrons in hydrogen one
are in their ground state 1s then you
would see a peak and this would be
you know that it would be at minus 13.6
right that would be the energy that it
takes to ionize it
and and this would be the 1s uh peak
and that's what you measure now it gets
more fun because now
i can also look at other elements so
let's draw helium
underneath it i'm going to try to
squeeze it in
if i look at helium well helium is also
1s and its pes
would be so this is now
ionization energy this is the pes plot
and the pes for helium would be also
the 1s but the relative counts
would be twice as high so the peak of
helium would be twice as high
as the peak of hydrogen because you know
for the same
number of photons in i'm getting that
many more i've got both these electrons
coming out
right so the relative peaks
the relative peaks i got two more that
can come out
right so this p now if i go to okay now
it gets really interesting because now
i'm oh
i even have room which is making me very
happy
because now i can do lithium right here
and if you look at lithium
lithium goes like this
right and if i look at a pes
plot of lithium the ionization energy
and the relative
electron count okay i'm going to have
those 1s electrons filled
and there's going to be another energy
where the 2s electrons are so this is
energy here
these are the orbitals and then
somewhere over here is going to be
a peak that's exactly half as high
exactly i mean that makes a lot of sense
because there's half as
right there's twice as many electrons
it's the relative electron count in the
atom
there's twice as many electrons coming
out of that
1s orbital in the 2s so i'm going to get
a half as high peak here
right and and usually now this i just
told you
the lithium atom this electron is 5
point something four ish electron volts
to remove
this is 122. so literally for lithium
this would be 122. this would be 5.4
and you know it's ionization energy and
ev
and what you would do is you would draw
the axis like that so you don't have to
put this all the way over here
right so we often what and all this
means is i've broken up
you know the the axis and it's
continuing to count here
in a different scale right
these pes plots are absolutely essential
in understanding uh atoms
and materials because look at what you
get you get
literally the electron filling plot
turned over
it's incredible you get it turned over
and you can write this as oh let's just
do this story you know
i could write this as 1s2 we have so
many options now 2s1
right i could write this as
helium 2s1 that would be like using the
noble gas
right i could make what people you know
there's so many
i can make box plots oh box plots
you can do this some people really like
putting things in boxes
1s 2s box plots
right so this is all meaning these
all say the same thing
lithium they all say lithium
right photoelectron spectra so i could
ask you questions like this
there's one ionization energy megajoules
per mole
relative number of electrons this
element has a charge of two plus and the
pes shown below what is it
i said well okay i know one s two
two s two and since this is going up
three times as high that sure looks like
two p
six doesn't it that looks like two 2p6
remember it's this turned over on its
side right where the peak height
corresponds to the filling
that's what that experiment gives you
2p6 well then it must
you have your periodic table uh-huh
because then tight
neon it must be neon
no who said no no don't just
yes it can't be neon because of the
question
it's got a charge of two plus oh
tricky tricky tricky
magnesium it must be magnesium that is
the pe
right but it's magnesium two plus
because i said it had a char
thank you shout out i appreciate that
okay so that's how that's the power of
the photoelectron spectra and we'll be
using it
in the class and this tells us about how
electrons
leave atoms it tells us about ionization
energies not just the first
which is the one all the way out here to
the right on the pes plot but all of
them
because i shine enough energy light to
get them all out
now you can also so that's about losing
electrons
you can also gain them and um and so
i mentioned this um a little bit but i
just for completeness i want to come
back to this you have electro
you have ionization energy right
which is how much energy it takes to
pull an electron out you also have
electron affinity and because some atoms
also uh might want electrons
and so when you look at those plots it's
actually all makes sense again
look at this some atoms like chlorine
this is electron affinity by atom number
some atoms like chlorine really want
another electron why
because it's got an incomplete shell
it's so it's so close it just needs one
more electron
to fill that outer shell and it wants it
and that's the electron affinity is how
much does it want it now
want happiness happiness lower energy
that's what this so if you're not going
to lower your energy
with another electron then you're just
saying no you
just say no zero i will not take an
electron
because if you give me one my energy is
going to go up and i will be a less
happy atom and you can make
that makes sense too right filled shells
they don't nitrogen
nitrogen's got a a half-filled shell no
to that electron
i like my half-filled shell it gives me
a little added stability
a little extra kick if you give me that
electron
you know i'm gonna have not have that
added stability i don't want it
zero right zero
losing electrons gaining electrons
losing electrons gaining electrons
why does it matter why does it matter
well we made a solid last week today the
answer is obvious
it matters because of danish wind
obviously 43
in 2014 43 of all the electrical energy
in denmark came from wind
it's higher now but see now this is a
quarter of the danish wind
i got i only gave you a two minute
hemodialysis
why this matters on wednesday so i'm
going extended today
just a little bit but danish wind
people are very dependable so over a
three-month period
this is how much we need energy
electricity
but that look at the wind supply that
but sometimes it's really there for us
sometimes it's not at all there
sometimes it's predictable sometimes
it's not at all predictable
with that much of your electricity
coming from this type of unreliable
resource that is a huge challenge now
even if you go out to arizona
and you talk about solar system
arizona's sunny all the time no
not sunny all the time most of the time
more than boston
but this is the sun in arizona that's
the power you're getting from it
and look at this these these are just
clouds because arizona does have clouds
and they passed by and they blocked the
sun do you know what a nightmare this is
for a grid operator
if a lot of your customers get their
energy
in this way yeah and all of a sudden
you know half of your supply of energy
just turns off
right i mean that's a huge problem right
and this is one of the most
limiting factors for increasing
to a large extent the amount of
renewables we have on our grid
and so of course i know a lot of you are
thinking well just store it and that's
what we need to do
right but it turns out that really one
of the only ways we have to store energy
at this large scale
is pumped hydro and you see we're
pumping water up up a hill
when i have excess i pump water up a
hill
and then when i need i roll it back down
and i turn a turbine with it right i'm
literally just
trading energy potential energy right
and then i bring it back kinetic energy
and then i make electricity
now the problem is that pumped hydro you
know pump
well as you can see pumped hydra is
going to be good where there's hydro
where there's water
so that's limiting but it also is a very
low
uh aerial density and there are also a
lot of uh
environmental challenges with making
this work in a way that doesn't
uh harm the environment so there are a
lot of issues with scaling up pumped
hydro
a lot of issues as a storage and so i
asked well what else can we pump up
hills
and we know what the answer is because
it's what we're talking about
ions where are they ions we can pump
ions up hills
there's my picture look at that right
ions and you know what this is it's a
battery
a battery is two different materials two
different metals a and b
where one of them has an ion i don't
know like lithium
for example
that can go back and forth and the
electrolyte is this thing in between
that only allows that ion through okay
now here's the thing so if i'm a metal
and i lose a positively charged atom
right well then i got to stay neutral
the only way to stay neutral is to pump
an electron out
right is to put on so so if i want to
draw electrons out of this
that's fine as long as i draw ions out
of it and then both of them can do work
and then they come back and they roll
down
an energy hill that's what they're doing
and going back and forth shuttling
back and forth back and forth they're
rolling down a hill literally
of energy yeah when it's in one metal
it's higher in energy
and then when i plug it up you know plug
my phone in
it rolls down that energy hill
right and as it does it travels across
to the other other metal gets lower in
energy and the electrons got to come
around and do work for me because
otherwise
it wouldn't stay neutral that's what a
battery is it's all about ions
right it's all about ions it's like a
ski lift i like to think of it
you know it's like these ions are
getting in into a ski lift they're just
getting
you know up the mountain and then when
you plug it in they're ready to ski down
and they go down and that's just
cruising across this electrolyte
right and i don't know what the electron
is in this analogy but that's all the
battery is
you plug it in and the ski lift takes it
up
right when you charge it and now you you
power your phone on and it
rolls back down well see the thing is
that batteries have seen
a moore's law of themselves
if you look at the moore's law for
batteries it uh
doubles right so this is the battery
energy storage of batteries
over the last 150-ish years it doubles
every 60 years
that's not a very good more zone but
that's completely changed
that's completely changed recently and
the reason is
all about ion shuttling materials
and ion storing materials this is why
this has happened this is why we've had
a revolution
in electrochemical energy storage right
because
150 years ago we only made batteries out
of about 10 different materials and
today
there's well over 80 that are
commercialized
there's many hundreds in research labs
that
what is making the difference is that
those materials now
allow the shuttling to happen it allows
the shuttling to happen more easily
maybe faster and it allows more of them
to be stored
per volume it's all about the chemistry
that houses those ions all about the
chemistry of the ions
so that's why this matters now we we uh
we roll things down hills
to power our world i told you this
already in the first or second lecture
we roll things down hills all the time
right so like methane is
you know the core ingredient in natural
gas and what we do and we talk about
combustion already
is we light that methane on fire but see
the thing is that what
nature has done is it has put all this
stuff
up the hell for us right so
over tens of millions of years nature
has pushed
the chemistry up a hill that is
literally what it's done
right in energy because you know it it's
made it so that if i have this rea if i
like this on fire it will go down the
hill it will roll down the hill
and give off energy right
nature has done that for us but see we
need to be able to do this
as well as nature and uh and so in the
last
uh minute of this why this matters i
want to explain why this is so
challenging
we need to be able to match because if
you look at the energy per weight
versus the energy per volume of a
material
that's a very important metric we plot
this all the time if you work on energy
materials
the volumetric versus the gravimetric
energy
density this is good a lot of energy per
weight and volume well look at where
gasoline is
now i want to do some math here because
i think this
is very important because i want you to
see now if i take one liter of gasoline
so if i take one liter
of gasoline
now the cost of that is around
the cost is around a dollar uh
it fluctuates but you know in this
country right around now it's about a
dollar
okay now if i look at how much energy
is in that gasoline the energy
stored in those bonds that nature has
pushed up a hill over millions of years
the energy stored is about 33 megajoules
okay good now i'm going to make a
comparison
one mit professor
one nit
professor operates
at around 60 watts now
this is something like well this is
equal to
60 joules per second now i know some
professors who can operate a little
higher than that
maybe some a little lower but that's
like the average right
60 joules per second now the thing is if
i want to get
33 mega joules out of this professor
then i get i get at this rate 33
megajoules takes the prof
um uh 153 hours
now here's why this matters because 153
hours will cost about fifteen hundred
and thirty dollars at
the uh mit uh professor salary
uh which is around
ten dollars per hour okay
and okay but look at this
i dug something out of the ground that
nature spent 100 million years making
fine
okay and i burned it and i got it for a
dollar i got the same amount of energy
that it would have taken me
literally fifteen hundred and thirty
dollars to pay for
that's our challenge right that's our
because now you can plot other things
here but look at this ethanol wood okay
liquid hydrogen we're still trying to
compress it get but look at this
batteries are way down there this is why
this matters because we're not even
close to being done
we're not even close see that great
uptick in electrochemical storage
we need another order or two of
magnitude still
right in storing energy efficiencies
costs etc so that's uh that's my why
this matters for
today now back to ions and electrons and
atoms
what i want to take the last 15 minutes
of class is to introduce a new way of
looking at this and some of you may have
seen the lewis dots
okay um we're gonna
i'm gonna introduce them today and then
we're gonna make a whole bunch of
molecular structures on wednesday
um and the reason this is so important
is that it gives us a sense
of these outer electrons it gives us a
sense
of how those outer electrons look right
for the atoms and then very importantly
how they come together in bonds
okay how they come together in bots so
um
so if i uh
just very very simply ask what is
you know what is the lewis dot
structure look like well
first of all the number of dots
is equal to the number of
valence electrons
and this is equal to the last digit
of the group so
of the element group i'll show you that
in a second
okay so there's lewis now lewis um
you know he's so there's one of his his
drawings in one of his original papers
in the early 1900s
he actually was a professor here as well
um and then he he went and did some of
this a lot of this work out in berkeley
so they named the hall after him
um and his comprehension was absolutely
profound
because in thinking about
atoms with dots to represent electrons
in the outer valence it gave us a way
to so easily think about bonding
okay now we can think about ionic
bonding for sure which is what we've
done
but more importantly what lewis helps us
with is to think about
covalent bonding and that's the subject
of wednesday okay which is a whole
another type of bonding that we're going
to talk about
okay now okay so now uh last digit of
the element group okay good so there it
predicts the number of bonds formed by
most elements in their compounds good
and there's the dots look at that
example fluorine
or using noble gas notation
helium that really saved us time i
didn't have to write one s2
actually this looks like four strokes of
the pen one s2 would have been three
i don't know honestly but anyway uh okay
there's fluorine and look one dot no
two dots no because you add a dot for
the valence so fluorine
has seven dots until you reach the
valence
until you reach the valence that is the
key
of the of the lewis picture because we
and we talked about this before
we talked about this before because so
there are three
really important things that come out of
the lewis picture
one is it tells us
as i've just told you it tells us about
bond formation
tells us about bond formation and
it makes the assumption that the valence
electrons
are what matter
for chemistry and this is critical and
i've alluded to this before
you now have a real sense of this though
from these energy diagrams you have a
sense of this
because look if i want to rip an
electron off of lithium i got to spend
5.4 electron volts
if i want to rip the next one off i got
to spend over a hundred electron volts
and we say well we'll do pes with all
these
energies it doesn't matter i'll get them
all but what if i just want to say well
who's going to you know what what
electrons are going to be
available to participate
in something like a bond which ones it's
going to be these ones
it's not going to be the ones all the
way in close to the core
that don't want to be bothered and
they've got so much energy
just to get their attention takes 100 ev
and even that's not a but here a little
visible light
and i got i got lithium talking to me
well it's the same you know chemically
it's the same these
that's light right these are these ones
are the ones
that want to and can participate in
bonding
the ones all the way down in energy way
way way low
they're inert they're inert right
so most of chemistry happens in the
violence and lewis
really nailed that right so these dots
are only
valence electron dots
and there's one more rule now okay so
there's those seven dots for fluorine
and then okay sometimes
you'll see this oh this is just the
number of dots it's this classification
of the uh of the columns
right the groups in the pair but no that
is not okay
not standard remember the iupac
which throws the best most lively
parties
and conferences they decide on how to
name elements and many many
other aspects of our lives are decided
by them and they said no
that's an old classification it's
confusing so we're going to go
with the standard which is that we still
count 1 to 18
1 to 18 1 2 s block
13 to 18 p block right
right okay that's cool we now right
3 to 12. d block oh
we go back and forth but it's still but
you can just take the last digit there
iupac even the periodic table talks
about it
it shows it it shows the old
classification there and then it says no
don't use it it's confusing and then why
do they show it
because some textbooks still show it so
you so i want
you to be aware of that okay
now you can use
louis you can use this idea of only
thinking about the the valence
to understand when atoms have similar
chemistry
right so if the valence of carbon
is the same as the balance of silicon
you bump down one quantum number
but they both have four electrons out
there in the valence
in this case it's two in this case it's
three in terms of quantum number but
they both have those same
kinds of and same number of electrons so
you could maybe expect
there to be similar chemistry it turns
out in this case
there's very different but we'll learn
about that carbon hybridization
silicon no we'll get to that
but still this is how we see silicon now
we don't see it this way with lewis
we see it this way this is how we see
carbon
right and so i want you to start seeing
elements this way
okay and so you can look at periodic
tables and and take images randomly
found online
with lewis dots and you can start
thinking
of atoms as their lewis dot
representation
okay and like i said on wednesday we're
going to make a whole bunch of
structures molecules
with lewis dots and and show how that
teaches us
not only about how to draw the bonds but
literally about which config which
bonding if i have sodium and chlorine
it's pretty obvious
if there's a bond it's between sodium
and chlorine
right but as i go to more and more atoms
and i'm trying to form molecules
it's not so obvious what is bonded to
what
and how right and thinking about
this and thinking about the third
part of what lewis did that was so
important
is what allows us to draw a whole bunch
of molecules octet rule
which is that atoms
like
and we now know like means
lower energy to reach eight
electrons in
their valence okay well we can already
see this
for the ionic bond that we've talked
about and you can
you can write this and i want you to
write ionic bonds
using lewis but in this case it's
actually pretty
straightforward right if i had for
example uh let's
let's get some more board space
over here
if i had for example an ionic bond
between cesium and fluorine
so if i had cesium
and fluorine then the way i would think
about this
in the lewis world would be
this way and
this way
because i've got seven valence electrons
in fluorine and one in cesium
and then if i write this as an ionic
bond the way i would write it is
cesium plus
with fluorine having taken
that electron now i'm not
and so you would write this still with
the minus sign there that emphasizes
it emphasizes what happened but i see my
lewis here
you know i see it there but i'm
emphasizing that this is an ionic
bond that's happened because fluorine
has wasn't supposed to have eight but
then it did
it's got a super high electron affinity
cesium has a very low ionization energy
of its first electron
and so fluorine just took it it
literally just took it
i'll take that thank you very much you
know i'm not being judgmental
but ionic bonds are kind of you know the
relationship
in a bond and i don't want to judge but
the relationship is not even
it's not even and it's okay but they
because what flooring said take
take give and see okay fine
now on wednesday when we do covalent
bonds it's not so then there's a lot
more sharing
that happens but here and that's why we
can model
it the way that i yes i still left there
we can model it that way
because it is like a charged atom in
another charged atom
right and it's because flooring took it
laureen took it it's okay any kind of
relationship
you know they get along they make it
work now
what we can also do and just in thinking
about this
just in thinking about this i could go
to another example like calcium
and if i think about calcium and
fluorine well i know again fluorine
likes to be f minus but see calcium when
i think about it as a lewis
atom yeah calcium likes to lose both of
those
calcium often because remember they want
to get to that
the octet rule they want to reach their
va
they're eight electrons but calcium's
got two what do i do either somebody
gives me six
not going to happen or i can lose two
and so what you get is that calcium will
go you know
to ca2 plus and but fluorine is still
just
f minus right from this i know that the
balanced stoichiometry
that is to say how many calcium atoms i
need
to stabilize this whole ionic bond
situation
is going to be two right i gotta go to
calcium
f2 and if i were going to write this as
with emphasizing the ionic bond i might
put brackets around just so it's really
easy to see
two plus there's no dots left because
now i'm writing it in a way where i've
emphasized
that because in tight that f took it
it took it and it is minus
and there's two of them you see
so that would be like thinking about an
ionic bond
right but from the lewis dot advantage
point where i really
see that flooring took the charge
okay okay so i think
and you can go further
you can go further i think we'll stop
there and on wednesday like i said
we're going lewis all the way and we're
doing covalent
molecules covalent bonds
you